so unless you've avoided news of all
kinds for the last four or five days you
probably know that things in the United
States have gotten extremely intense on
top of a global hundred year pandemic
coronavirus where the United States has
been one of the worst hit countries
thanks in part to our failed federal
leadership we have seen the tragedy of
George Floyd being killed by police in
Minnesota set off a string of extreme
civil unrest and this includes examples
of just about everything you can imagine
both by protesters and by those who are
pretending to be protesters but actually
have nefarious intentions and by police
as well and meanwhile we are completely
lacking anything that would be called
leadership from The Oval Office with
Donald Trump doing everything from
calling for protestors to gather at the
White House on Saturday night which they
didn't all the way to tweeting about
essentially release the hounds
talking about secret services vicious
dogs that would be unleashed on
protesters who breached the fence at the
White House up to and including flying
to Florida and taking credit for a
SpaceX launch of a falcon 9 rocket
carrying two astronauts to the
International Space Station while
retweeting videos of himself talking
about all of it Saturday as protests
raged and buildings burned and I really
spent a lot of time this weekend
thinking about what's the primary story
here what's like the main analysis that
has to be done what's the lens through
which we need to understand what's
happening in our country right now
because I wanted to come to you and give
you that point of view here's really
what this is about and the conclusion I
came to is that there is no one lens
things are more complicated then this is
really what's going on and I know that
there are a ton of hot takes about this
if you look at Twitter lately if you
look at cable news everybody claims to
hold the real key they claim to say this
is the true filter through which this
should all be seen I'm here to tell you
I don't have such a lens for you because
I believe any such lens is too
simplistic now if you want that
simplistic analysis there are plenty
available there's no question about it
but to some degree we sometimes are
blinded by narrative and in some cases
if all you have is a hammer everything
looks like a nail meaning if you want to
see every issue as being related to one
problem you're able to find a way to do
that even if it's not really the right
or most robust analysis so I'm gonna
give you some examples and then we'll
get to what I think is a reasonable
analysis and way to think about all of
this so one story line we're hearing and
we've heard it from a lot of different
people is this is merely about race this
is about white cops killing black people
this is about white cops oppressing
black protesters this is about a
fundamentally racist justice system it's
about a fundamental fundamentally racist
society it's it that's what the lens is
now of course rage race is a massive
component that is causing understandable
rage among a lot of people but that
analysis doesn't tell you everything
that you need to know our economic
system at its core for example functions
to stymie and suppress real change in
activism and it goes way beyond race has
racial implications of course but you
miss that if you make this only about
race much of that economic system is
certainly rooted in supremacist along
racial lines but a race only analysis
falls short a lot of the hot cakes we're
seeing or are only about race another
perspective that is heavily represented
is that this is really about capitalism
right any capitalist system is
inevitably racist and inevitably leads
to this degree of social unrest arson
looting property damage police violence
against protesters protesters
against police protests our own protests
or violence protesters versus looters
that the the idea is that is because of
a capitalist system making this simply
about capitalism ignores the countless
social democracies right which that's a
form of capitalism is regulated
capitalism that are some of the places
where these issues of inequality and
racial tensions have been best dealt
with around the world some of the best
examples in fact of functioning
societies with reduced income inequality
reduced racial inequality social safety
nets trust in institutions less
corruption they are regulated versions
of capitalism so I believe that the
capitalism analysis also fails another
lens that's being presented as the lens
is simply about police brutality meaning
this is about police brutality as what
killed George Floyd this is about police
brutality as the problem in the protests
in other words if it weren't for police
brutality George Floyd would be alive if
George Floyd were alive we wouldn't be
seeing these protests we at the protests
are also just seeing further police
brutality now there is no shortage of
police brutality at the protests what
happened the George Floyd is
unconscionable but this is about so much
more than that including economic and
racial issues it's about the
militarization of law enforcement in the
United States and there are people
making it only about that it's not only
about that but that's that's a part of
it when you militarized law enforcement
you create overly aggressive policing
you can argue that that played a role in
George Floyd's death militarization is
what led police in riot gear in dozens
of cities over the weekend to use tear
gas and rubber bullets and to see media
and random bystanders and even people
peacefully protesting which is of course
their right to do horribly injured by
police so militarization of law
enforcement is another huge problem in
the u.s. we've covered it but it is not
the only lens that we need to be using
so here's the reality when you think
about this and we often want things to
be black and white we
say this is what this is really about
the reality is this is a country of 331
million people we have examples of
everything you can imagine we have
dozens of different problems that relate
to what we are now seeing just this
weekend we saw sickening violence done
by police to protesters including for
example an elderly man with a cane
shoved onto the ground by police and we
saw police and I believe it was Michigan
show up and tell the protesters I'm
putting down my weapons I'm with you
let's march together we saw protesters
burn entire buildings and brutalize
business owners including middle-aged
women and yet we also saw protesters
guard a police officer who was separated
from his squad on Saturday night and
this is the risk about the out of
context sharing of pictures and video on
social media ten seconds from one
protest and 15 from another and and I
actually did some of this over the
weekend and I don't know that it was the
best thing not only does it lack
immediate context it lacks broader
context about all of the issues that
have gotten us to where we are now
including by the way a complete lack of
leadership from the President and we're
going to talk about that later which is
why I'm not digging into it too much
right here so my message is what we are
seeing is mostly about systems and it is
less about individuals you're seeing a
ton of debates about what portion of
police are good versus bad which is very
fraught terminology anyway good good and
bad what portion of protesters have good
or bad intentions what portion of
protesters are grassroots members of the
community versus out-of-town astroturf
furs as has been a growing narrative
over the weekend used in part to
discredit the real and justified anger
that protesters have about what's going
on in their communities the problem is
if you just argue about that if you
spend your time on those questions well
82% of the protesters are good or
whatever you might say you're not really
digging into the systemic elements at
play if we figure out it's 85% of the
protesters that are good instead
of 80 then what it's good fodder for
corporate media it does little for
anybody else so I don't pretend to have
one single unifying theory about this
this is what it's really about and at
the exclusion of other things that's not
something you're going to hear from me
but what I can tell you for sure is that
you won't understand any of this if you
don't understand the context and that's
where a lot of the local news coverage
of the protests has failed which is a
complete lack of context Oh somebody
looted a Cheesecake Factory and they
came out with the cheesecake that's
coverage that we saw doesn't really tell
us anything about what's going on so
racialized policing combined with a
two-tiered justice system for rich and
poor a system that focuses on street
crime at the exclusion of white-collar
crime combined with an economic system
that doesn't work for a huge portion of
the country in addition to right now
having nearly 25 percent unofficial
unemployment in the midst of a hundred
year pandemic in addition to a complete
absence of federal leadership from a
president who tweeted all weekend from
his bunker at the White House
combined with corporate media that
really is seeking to foment division
rather than find solutions doesn't it's
not a good recipe and then you add to
that militarized law enforcement that
seems to always have money despite we
supposedly lacking mar supposed lack of
money for health care and education it's
all of that stuff together now I want to
be really clear this is not like a
social justice intersectionality
analysis of race and gender and relates
it's not that what it is is an
understanding that we have systems in
our country that are bigger than any one
protest or any one police officer and
only with that multi focus perspective
can you really get anything that we
would call an all-encompassing analysis
let me give you another example of a
false debate riots are good versus riots
are bad or riots are effective versus
the riots are ineffective or they are
criminal or they are heroic first of all
a ton of this debate is actually
semantics in terms of some people are
arguing over whether riots are good or
bad
others are arguing over what counts as a
riot versus a protest
there's racialization of the language
there's a lack of context etc but what
you really have to understand is you can
simultaneously say I'm against violence
both against people and property I
believe is that it is unlikely that the
violence will achieve much and yet at
the same time I understand that people
have had it and I get what's going on
right someone's a son is killed by
police and then a window gets smashed
it's hard to feel like these things are
equivalent in any way without needing to
endorse property damage we can
understand that people have absolutely
had it people are sick and tired of the
status quo and while I might not think
we will achieve change by breaking
windows I understand and sympathize with
the absolute anger and disgust with
these systems that protesters have now I
have to tell you the argument that the
unrest has accomplished nothing I don't
know if it's a good argument you all
know that I have always said I favor
legal protests I'm against violence and
get including against most forms of
property crime over the weekend we saw
the officer who killed George Floyd
Derek shavon arrested we saw Fox News
Sunday devote an hour to the protests to
George Floyd and to how coronavirus
disproportionately affects communities
of color with guests Cornel West I don't
know that were it not for the national
unrest we would have seen that be the
Fox News Sunday show I don't know I I
think that what's what we're seeing
played a role in what Fox News even
decided to do on Sunday would we have
seen Derek shavon get arrested would we
potentially be seeing the other three
officers get arrested were it not for
this degree of unrest I don't know is
the question it's less clear to me that
this has accomplished nothing and that
is separate from whether these are
tactics that I condone last thing and I
want to be really clear here this is not
like some kumbaya segment
where everyone's thoughts are equally
valid and everyone is equally
responsible for what's going on that's
not what this is but what we need to
understand is that the word privilege is
often thrown around you're privileged if
you say cops are mostly good and protect
you because a lot of people live in
places where the cops aren't primarily
there to protect you
or at least it certainly doesn't feel
that way if you're part of certain
communities or you're privileged to be
against property crime during protests
because you lived somewhere safe and the
systems work for you and you can't
possibly imagine what it's like to
actually be in the position that a lot
of the protesters are in in some way all
of those allegations are correct and yet
this is not so much about individual
privilege it's again systems that aren't
working for large swaths of people and
that gets me to my last thought in
history we've seen unrest lead to
movements which lead to activism which
will often enter the political and legal
space which at some point will end up
being decided by a judge somewhere look
at Brown v Board of Education the
landmark position decision that said
states can't segregate schools by race
that was in 1954 it started in 1951 in
Kansas it involved three years of
activism protests consensus building and
eventually it was a Supreme Court
decision under Earl Warren that decided
nine to zero on the court schools can't
racially segregated x' to happen next do
not miss the forest for the trees that
may come one two or three years down the
line if what is going on now will lead
to change it may come down to who is on
the Supreme Court in one two or three
years I don't even have to tell you what
that means about a decision we all have
to make five months from now because you
all know exactly what that decision is